two brothers have become the latest
casualties of near daily confrontations
between Palestinians and Israel's
military
they leave behind another family broken
with grief and another Palestinian
Community angry and frustrated
Israel's military says daffa and Joad
rimawi were in an area where stones and
petrol bombs were being thrown at a
patrol
the Israeli occupation forces fatally
shot Jawad his brother Duffer tried to
save him he called for help Witnesses
heard him calling for an ambulance but
the Israeli forces shot him in the chest
the youngest Duffer was at University
studying I.T hundreds of his fellow
students turned out to mourn the
brothers as their bodies were taken for
burial
this is the most violent year in the
occupied West Bank for 16 years
according to the UN
EMA we've spoken with the International
Community to curb ongoing Israeli crimes
against our people were determined to
join International organizations and
take perpetrators to the international
court of justice in the West Bank's main
city Ramallah there was a general strike
to show solidarity with the latest
victims of violence Palestinian prime
minister Mohammed shatia says the
upsurge in violence is a harbinger of
things to come he's referring to the new
Israeli government which will have in it
for the first time far-right Jewish
nationalist politicians in ministerial
posts able to influence the daily lives
of Palestinians living under occupation
that doesn't sound like a formula that
will lead to the calming of tensions
here
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Ramallah